global demand for food
and animal source food in particular is
increasing
the growing livestock sector brings new
opportunities and challenges
for food security and nutrition
livelihoods and economic growth
animal health and welfare and natural
resources and climate change for decades
agriculture and the livestock sector
have tried to produce more from less
and to maximize output sustainably
the un 2030 agenda raised the bar
introducing further dimensions to the
goal of sustainability
however the world is currently off track
to achieve many of the sustainable
development goals by 2030 and the kobit
19 pandemic
has made this even harder
how can the livestock sector help to
achieve the sustainable development
goals
livestock can help to end hunger and
malnutrition
by ensuring healthy and nutritious diets
contributing to
incomes and providing vulnerable
populations with adequate and reliable
supplies of nutritious
affordable and safe food
livestock can contribute to poverty
reduction and economic growth
by supporting the livelihoods of large
numbers of rural people
helping to alleviate poverty creating
employment
stimulating demand for goods and
services and feeding
into other sectors of the economy
livestock can contribute to ecosystem
services
by supporting biodiversity and key
ecosystem functions
nutrient cycling and soil carbon
sequestration
livestock can increase resilience by
helping hundreds of millions of people
to survive in marginal areas due to
their versatility
when integrated with crop tree or fish
farming livestock helped to increase
their outputs
spread risks withstand shocks and adapt
to changing climatic conditions
the livestock sector is important for
each sdg but there are challenges
that need to be managed livestock
contributes significantly to climate
change
they are the biggest agricultural land
user can cause biodiversity loss
and draw heavily on natural resources
intensification of animal production
could compromise animal health and
welfare
this also threatens human health through
antimicrobial overuse
and increased risk from zoonotic
diseases
in a more competitive sector it is
difficult to ensure inclusive access to
markets
for small-scale farmers and pastoralists
women
and youth due to these complex
interactions
enhancing livestock's contribution to
the 2030 agenda
requires a holistic and inclusive
approach
fao is supporting members to integrate
livestock policies and practices
with sustainable development strategies
around the world
together with governments international
communities the private sector
farmers and other actors we can ensure
growth is socially economically
and environmentally sustainable promote
inclusive and efficient livestock
markets
make sure animal products are safe
prevent
and respond to livestock related
emergencies like diseases or natural
disasters
promote best practices for animal health
and welfare
use evidence-based tools and guidelines
to shape policies and practices
[Music]
food and agriculture are at the heart of
solutions for many of the challenges the
world is currently facing
and sustainable livestock can help to
create a better life for billions of
people
together we can sustainably transform
the livestock sector
and contribute to the un sustainable
development goals
you